well let's go
let's talk about moore's law a little
bit it's uh uh
at the broad view of moore's law where
it's just exponential improvement of
uh computing capability
like openai for example recently
published this kind of
papers looking at the exponential
improvement
in the training efficiency of neural
networks for like imagenet and all that
kind of stuff we just got better on this
this is purely software side just
figuring out
better tricks and algorithms for
training neural networks
and that seems to be improving uh
significantly faster than the moore's
law prediction
you know so that's in the software space
they
what do you think if moore's law
continues
or if the general version of moore's law
continues
do you think that comes mostly from the
hardware from the software some mix of
the two
some interesting totally uh so not the
reduction of the size of the transistor
kind of thing but more in the uh
uh in the totally interesting kinds of
innovations in the hardware space all
that kind of stuff well
there's like a half a dozen things going
on in that graph
so one is there's initial innovations
that had a lot of head room to be
exploited
so you know the efficiency of the
networks has improved dramatically
and then the decomposability of those
and the use go
you know they started running on one
computer then multiple computers and
multiple gpus and arrays of gpus and
they're up to thousands and at some
point
so so it's sort of like they were
consumed they were going from like a
single computer application to a
thousand
computer application so that's not
really a moore's law thing that's an
independent vector how many computers
can i put on this problem
because the computers themselves are
getting better on like a moore's law
rate
but their ability to go from one to ten
to a hundred to a thousand
yeah you know was something and then
multiplied by
you know the amount of computes it took
to resolve like alex nat to resnat the
transformers it's
it's been quite you know steady
improvements
but those are like s-curves aren't they
yeah that's the exactly kind of uh
that are underlying moore's law from the
very beginning so
so what what's the biggest what's the
most uh productive
uh rich source of s-curves in in the
future do you think
is it hardware is it software or is it
so hardware is going to move along
relatively slowly like you know double
performance every two years
there are there's still i like how you
call that slow yeah that's the slow
version
the snail's pace of moore's law maybe we
should we should
we should uh trademark that one
whereas the scaling by number of
computers you know can go much faster
you know i'm sure at some point google
had a you know their initial search
engine was running on a laptop
you know like yeah and at some point
they really worked on scaling that and
then they factored
the indexer from you know this piece and
this piece and this piece and they
spread the data on more and more things
and
you know they did a dozen innovations
but as they scaled up the number of
computers on that
it kept breaking finding new bottlenecks
in their software and their schedulers
and
and made them rethink like it seems
insane to do a scheduler across a
thousand computers to schedule parts of
it and then send the results to one
computer
but if you want to schedule a million
searches that makes perfect sense
so so there's the the scaling by just
quantity is probably the richest thing
but then
as you scale quantity like a network
that was great on 100 computers may be
completely the
wrong one you may pick a network that's
10 times slower
on 10 000 computers like per computer
but if you go from 100 to 10 000 that's
100 times
so that's one of the things that
happened when we did internet scaling
this efficiency went down
not up the future of computing is
inefficiency not efficiency
but scales in efficient scale it's it's
scaling faster than inefficiency
bites you and as long as there's you
know dollar value there like scaling
costs lots of money
yeah but google showed facebook showed
everybody showed that the scale was
where the money was at
you